blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so you all know of course about
america first and the us
is the best and we're the best country
and we're the best at everything and we
have the best people and we have the
best
everything and yet um already canada has
surpassed the united states
in terms of the portion of uh adults
who have received a second or final dose
um yeah as i tweeted when this happened
quote you can buy i don't know if i need
to quote myself
as a david pakman from the weekend you
can buy
all the vaccines you want early but if
you're overrun with anti-vaxx americans
eventually canada catches up and if you
look at the vaccination curves for each
country
there's really a treasure trove of
information just in looking at the
shapes of these curves which we're going
to put up on the screen
for our video audience if you look at
the u.s vaccination curve
you see that it it picks up in mid-march
when we had
a lot of vaccines already and the trend
is that as more and more vaccines have
become available into may
june july where you can just walk in
anywhere no appointment get vaccinated
the rate of vaccination in the u.s has
slowed down
in the united states because we so
quickly
started hitting anti-vax resistance from
people who don't want the vaccine even
though vaccine supply continues to go up
the curve flattens and flattens to where
we are now
doing only about 500 000 vaccine doses
per day so the u.s
story as seen graphically here is
tons of vaccines rapidly waning interest
now in canada the curve started almost
flat why
well because the u.s had all the
vaccines and as vaccine supply
increased in canada the vaccination
curve
went almost vertical and importantly
it is sustaining in this way in the u.s
by the time we got to
35 40 doses of
people vaccinated the curve was
flattening canada has surpassed us
and is approaching 50 percent and it is
sustained as an almost vertical curve
uh in a month canada is in all
likelihood
going to be dramatically more vaccinated
than the united states
so this anti-vac stuff is lethal if you
are a
trumpist who falsely believes trump made
the vaccine
if you believe that why would you let
canada
take all of the vaccine protection from
us this is i mean this is such a dumb
way to see it
but as i as i tweeted yesterday maybe we
need to start marketing the vaccine to
trumpists
as a soda like the way sodas are
marketed to people and call it trump
juice
is that what it will take but if you are
a trumpist
wouldn't you want to honor your fearless
leader who made the vaccine
by getting the vaccine that he made for
you
instead of letting socialist communist
marxist canadians use it
remember this is all crazy i'm just
thinking how do we get trumpists to want
it and the gap is
is wild canada is currently vaccinating
about 1.2 percent of its population
daily
1.2 percent the u.s is fully vaccinating
0.2 percent of our population
daily and it's not because we have a
larger share vaccinated
canada has surpassed us now so this will
soon end up being
another complete humiliation
of the united states of america thanks
to right wingers
who are proud about not getting
vaccinated now
it's fine to say canada simply has fewer
people
that's why we're talking about
vaccination per
capita it is absolutely shameful that
the united states with all the vaccines
we have
is struggling this badly to find people
who want to get vaccinated while the
world is mostly
desperate for vaccines and actually
getting vaccinated as they get vaccines
available
these spikes we're seeing in the united
states
the masks already going back on in
certain places
expect more of it as people continue to
refuse to get vaccinated now i i want to
remind you
the good news continues to be for now
the vaccines provide very good
protection
against even the delta variant if you're
vaccinated and get sick
you're very unlikely to be seriously ill
very
unlikely to be hospitalized there's
places where for example at a certain
point last week
every hospitalized coveted patient in
los angeles california county
was not vaccinated that's fantastic but
there will be breakthrough cases
and remember the slower we vaccinate
the more those unvaccinated people can
be vectors
for the development of variants for
which the vaccines
are not well suited so this is a very
real issue
we're seeing it in the numbers we're
seeing it in the numbers of what's
happening in other countries
we're seeing it in the numbers of the
spikes that are taking place
some states florida for example just
exploding with cases and the
hospitalizations are starting to
increase
in mostly unvaccinated people if there's
any good news and it's never great for
me that people are getting sick and
dying but if there's any good news
it's that the decision to get yourself
vaccinated
remains a very good decision it's not a
hundred percent foolproof decision but
it is
very very good in the midst of all of
what is going on
uh including with the coveted spikes and
so many other things which we will talk
about today
president joe biden's approval is
soaring
among independents it is remaining high
among democrats
it is remaining low among republicans
but it is increasing
dramatically among independents and also
specifically on the issue of covet
handling
which now donald trump himself and many
republicans are actively antagonizing
the biden administration over
which we will also talk about today joe
biden getting as donald trump likes to
say
very high marks when it comes to um
the handling of the pandemic so let's
look
at a couple of articles about these
polls first of all
newsweek joe biden's approval rating
soaring among independents
joe biden's approval rating among
independents has soared following a
sharp decline at the end of june
according to an
ipsos survey the ipsos weekly approval
tracker
found that biden's rating among
independents stood at 52
in the latest survey the president's
overall approval rating is 53
disapproval is 42.
biden enjoys 88 approval among democrats
that's
very close to the to within the margin
of error down from 91
that's down three points but the margin
of error is three and a half
approval among republicans is uh up very
slightly
13 to 17 but the approval figure from
independent voters is up sharply
it hit uh the last time biden's approval
among independents
hit 50 percent was june 17th
he was down to 45 percent then he was
down to
34 among independents at the beginning
of july that's the lowest in the survey
since biden took office
and then it recovered to 44 and now to
52. why the president enjoys high
approval from
independence on covid pandemic with 59
approval which is in line with his
overall
approval that is a very very good sign
opinions on the president's performance
follow party lines
86 percent of democrats approve on his
covet approach
compared to just 33 percent of
republicans but i will tell you
33 percent approval on covet from
republicans when they are the the
uh covet is being used as a weapon
against joe biden
by republicans to say we can't trust the
vaccines which trump is now saying we
will get to that
um the too authoritarian when it comes
to masking or
vaccines or whatever the case to still
have one in three republicans support
you
when disinformation is this weaponized i
actually think is
still notable in some sense
let's look at more data here biden gets
66 approval from americans in pandemic
handling
this is from a cbs news yougov poll
26 of americans believe biden is doing a
very good job at managing the pandemic
but another 40 percent
think he's doing a somewhat good job
only 34 disapprove of biden's covet
handling
only 18 percent call it very bad people
said the country as a whole
is doing a better job now at getting the
covid
the coronavirus under control then what
was going on in january
polling from january and july
flip-flopped
64 now believe the pandemic is going
well
only 35 believed that it was going well
back in january so there's a few
different
takeaways here and important things
first of all
um when you go to republicans and you
say well what
how do you explain this it seems even
through your propaganda joe biden is
doing well particularly on this
many of them will say have you seen joe
biden's youtube live streams
and have you seen the down votes there's
often you know like
200 likes and 3 000 dislikes when joe
biden live streams
it is of no meaning or value at all
this is what republicans are doing they
what they call
they call it brigading or ratioing joe
biden's live streams and they dislike
them
it's not even a serious part of the
conversation but that's what they will
say
part of the reason that joe biden's
approval
isn't higher is that it has been a
right-wing media
concerted effort since joe biden was
sworn in
to simply assassinate character and make
wild allegations
about joe biden being a marxist
communist dictatorial authoritarian
right-wing media used to be 85 percent
about character assassination and lies
it's now 99 about character
assassination and lies it's been a
desperate race to see
who can come up with the most outrageous
lie about the quote democrat party
and socialist biden uh in part maybe
because of the vacuum created by the
death of rush limbaugh among right-wing
media now i do think there are some
independents
who maybe thought the lies about joe
biden were true
maybe joe biden was going to take their
guns maybe joe biden was going to force
them to be vegan maybe joe biden was
going to force them to
you know i don't know uh flush toilets
10 or 15 times
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
right um and it's not happening and some
of those independents are actually
saying oh you know what
maybe maybe that was crazy and i never
should have believed that and joe
biden's actually doing okay
as far as republicans are go many of
them are too far gone and
too indoctrinated to change their views
but there seem to be independents that
can see reason
and they're coming over to say i approve
of joe biden
and i approve of joe biden's handling of
some issues now the implications here
are twofold
the immediate implications continue to
be what is the impact on people simply
getting vaccinated because we're having
trouble vaccinating our way out of the
out of the pandemic because of half of
republicans who don't want to get that
vaccine that's the immediate question
in terms of electorally i think it's too
early to take this information
about biden's approval and say anything
about 2024
we don't even know if joe biden is
running in 2024. it's just too early it
doesn't tell us anything
but we are starting to be able to glean
some things about 2022. typically in
2022
based on history as we talked with
rachel bittikoffer almost exclusively
you would expect democrats to do poorly
in the house
maybe in the senate that's the way it
tends to go
party takes the white house two years
later they do poorly in the midterms
however it may not be that way if joe
biden continues to have
what is his you know in the modern
historical context a high approval
rating republicans really need swing
voters
to do well in 2022 the fact that
independents are the group that is most
heavily shifting
from being against joe biden to being in
favor of him approving of him
that's not a particularly good sign for
republicans now their answer
might be let's just suppress even more
of the vote
and they're trying to do that by
proposing more than 250 voter
suppression bills across 40 something
states so
we are starting to be able to talk about
2022
but still a long way to go before i
would be comfortable saying
i think it'll probably be okay for
democrats or it could be a bloodbath for
democrats we don't know yet we will have
a clearer picture
i think as we close in on september
where the 2022
races are expected to start getting
going early
and speaking of by september mid-august
august 16th listen to this it's the
david pakman show
16th anniversary 16th anniversary
august 16th we are going to be doing a
one-day membership
blowout on that day i really hope that
if you've enjoyed the show
or even if you don't but you you think
there's some value in it existing you
can dislike me but
maybe you think the show has some value
some redeeming quality
some redemptive quality please get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com because on
august 16th you'll get an email telling
you
how to take advantage of a one day
outrageous
outrageous membership special we'll take
a quick break
send me your thoughts about independence
shifting to biden
on twitter where you can find me at
deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
remember that we do have an extra show
that we do every day if you like this
show enough to want more of it like if
you're one of the rare folks who's like
oh you know what an hour a day is
actually not enough of this nonsense
we do an extra 15 to 20 minutes minutes
for our paid subscribers just become a
member at joinpacman.com and you'll get
instant access to what we call the bonus
show there is an
absolutely horrifying viral video out of
los angeles
of lapd shooting a woman at point-blank
range with what is believed to be either
a rubber
rubber bullet or a bean bag round
there's actually conflicting report
reports about this
we are going to look at the video the
video is it's sort of graphic it's
certainly
it's certainly disturbing it's it's sort
of graphic just as a warning
and we are going to look at that
momentarily but first some reports about
this
video shows lapd officers shoot
protester at close range with non-lethal
round
outside koreatown spa
video shows an lapd lapd officer
shooting a non-lethal round at a
protester
at close range as the department
responded to a clash between two groups
who held dueling demonstrations outside
a koreatown spa
over trans rights on saturday that was
the impetus
for this protest when officers arrived
in riot gear protesters started throwing
bottles and projectiles according to
authorities
some of them were pelted at officers
which prompted them to issue an order to
disperse
when some groups failed to leave less
than lethal force was deployed
the viral video shows one officer firing
the rubber bullet hitting a protester in
the stomach
she is seen falling to the ground the
woman's condition
was not immediately available there's
then another report
lgbtq plus activists shot with rubber
bullet
in la protest la lgbtq
activists gathered to counter a protest
against trans access to the spas
facilities
in la's koreatown neighborhood the video
shows lapd pointing guns at
demonstrators shooting rubberized
bullets using batons and pushing
journalists
one counter protester was shot with a
rubber bullet after shouting don't shoot
lapd captain alfonso lopez said in a
video interview shared on social
that police responded to projectiles
being thrown he stated the police
arrested 38 people so let's look at the
video
um and of course what's that issue here
is whether this particular protester i
don't deny for a second that there were
bottles being thrown at police
uh i saw videos of that i don't deny for
a second that an
uh an order to disperse was given the
question is why was this particular
person
shot at point blank range which by the
way is not the way
rubberized bullets are supposed to be
used let's take a look for those who are
watching here with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the woman holding a phone and you see
people rushing over to her as we
continue
to uh to to look at this and uh
uh at almost point blank range just
an unbelievable bit video and again it's
one of these things where
if there's an explanation for why that's
reasonable
i'm having a hard time even imagining it
because we
see what the woman is holding rubber
bullets
are very dangerous at close range most
police department policies have really
specific rules like a minimum distance
when these are going to be used
or when it comes to bean bag rounds i
believe it's
you bounce them off the ground or you
only target legs or these are for
dangerous non-compliant individuals not
someone who has their
hands up saying don't shoot holding
a phone um and so of course
you immediately see the um
right wingers come out and say well she
shouldn't have been there there was an
order to disperse
where are they on that exact explanation
for ashley babbitt
who was trespassing remember this was
not at the capitol this was out on the
street
um and the incredible hypocrisy that we
are seeing
particularly because of this ashley
babbitt trump riot january 6
story makes the crocodile tears
hear about well she shouldn't have been
there
she she was breaking no she wasn't
actually no she wasn't there was an
order
to disperse and the interpretation of
how quickly that's supposed to happen is
much like resisting arrest
something that police will often use to
start using more force than is necessary
or than as indicated
uh rubber bullets not even being used in
compliance with policy rubber of course
makes it sound
noticeable it's rubber it's sort of like
if someone throws a beach ball
at you um no rubber bullets
can be lethal they can be used
improperly and can be lethal
and i'm not even listen by the way
i'm not in favor of shooting the
anti-trans protesters
or the pro-trans protesters i don't want
any of them shot if people are just
protesting there's another layer here of
course
which is that there was an anti-trans
protest
going on outside the spa which triggered
counter protesters who are pro-trans
rights
and it's the pro-trans rights
counterprotester
who ends up getting herself shot somehow
the police still ended up shooting her
uh that's just sort of like a detail of
i'd call it irony but that makes it
sound less tragic than it actually is
but just horrifying horrifying video and
we're still getting more information
about this um we'll continue to follow
it and see what we ultimately find out
again the the protester who was shot's
condition
i was not able to find anything
definitive at least this morning when i
was researching the story
about what is going on with her at this
time but horrible horrible video
there is a stunning new poll from yougov
which finds that 66 percent of americans
i'm sorry
of republicans in the southern united
states
want to secede from the united states
and become their own country this was a
joint poll
between yougov and brightline watch and
they did some interesting things
uh one of the things that the poll does
is it breaks down the country by regions
so you've got like the pacific region
which is california washington oregon
hawaii
and alaska you've got all these the
northeast etc
and what they did was they reported
people's interest in
separating out as a country not at the
state level but as a region if your
region could become its own country
would you want to secede from the united
states
and they asked people this on the basis
of party affiliation so
let's look at some examples here in the
northeast region
as an example which includes maine new
hampshire vermont new york pennsylvania
massachusetts connecticut rhode island
you know a couple of
maryland delaware they said okay would
you want to be your own
country and secede from the united
states and for example
39 of democrats said yes we do we would
like to be our own region
35 percent of independents and only 26
percent of republicans said i would like
the northeast to be our own
region the largest level of support in
this poll across all regions and
political identifications
is southern republicans if you look at
the southern region
that includes texas florida and a bunch
of other states
66 percent of republicans said yeah
i want to secede i would like our region
the southern
region to be its own country now the
absolute
most ironic thing about this is that the
southern region
would be completely unsustainable
economically
some of the states that are the biggest
takers
rather than givers when it comes to
federal money
would be in that southern region so said
a different way
some of the states that are the most
dependent on money that comes from other
states
through the federal government are
mississippi
kentucky south carolina louisiana
alabama tennessee arkansas and oklahoma
they're all in what we would be this
southern region of the united states
texas and florida are kind of in the
middle they're not terrible they're not
great in terms of paying in versus
getting out
so the point here is the group that most
wants to secede from the united states
southern republicans
and make their own country out of their
region
are the ones who states are the least
economically able to do that
and the most dependent on blue states to
subsidize them this isn't new
we've covered this we've done stories
about this before about this contrast
before
it's been true for a very long time now
consider the reality versus perception
their perception is things are really
bad
being part of the united states why
because of democrats
and liberals and progressives like joe
biden's communism and his socialism
and the marxist democrats woke culture
is ruining us
cancel cultural culture is ruining us
men in girls
sports as they love to say it's ruining
the country
and we'd be better off if we separated
and did our own thing that's the
perception that many of them have
the reality is none of that stuff is
actually going on
there are almost no socialists in the
democratic party and however bad things
are in your state
in terms of education and they're very
bad in a lot of these states
however bad things are in your state in
terms of access to health care
infrastructure
it would be even worse if you lost the
subsidies you get from blue states
through the federal government
blue states that are paying in much more
than they get out
and making your education system be
slightly less terrible
making your health care system be
slightly less terrible making your
infrastructure
slightly less terrible it couldn't
possibly be more backwards and they have
the idea these southern republicans
if we separated and did our own thing we
would be much better off
but again in a sense just like i don't
take
joy in the anti-vaccine nurse that just
died of covid
because i see her as a victim of
disinformation it's very similar for
lots of these people
who wrongly blame their problems on
imaginary issues
rather than the real failures of their
almost exclusively republican
state and local level elected officials
they are also the victims of
disinformation they are persistently
victims by the way also
of a terrible education system in their
states
they can't even follow simple logic like
oh pandemic
okay mask for now and then vaccine once
we can get it
they can't even follow that so they are
also victims to some degree now we'll
have a voicemail about this with a
different perspective a little bit later
on
last thing on this it shouldn't come as
a shock
that the group that most glorifies the
side of the confederacy during the civil
war
is the one that most wants to secede
from the union that's
actually consistent that's not
surprising
and so it shouldn't come as a shock to
us we're gonna have more coverage of
this poll
on our instagram so make sure you're
following us there at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and we will get
to the decidedly
overtly anti-vaxx shift among many
prominent republicans that took place
over this past weekend
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
so there is a completely perplexing but
absolutely depraved and immoral
anti-vaccine campaign that is now being
waged
by the former guy by the former
president donald trump
and despite taking credit for the
vaccine
despite that it will increasingly be his
supporters who get sick and die
if they refuse to get vaccinated donald
trump has now put out a statement
that is mirroring the exact anti-vaccine
language of the right-wing media that
republicans aren't getting vaccinated
because
they don't trust the biden
administration politically even though
remember even by their claim biden had
nothing to do with making the vaccine
this is the trump vaccine now of course
you and i know
trump didn't really have anything to do
with the vaccine other than he agreed to
have
the government pre-purchase some doses
which most countries do
and we'll get back to that but let's
first look at the statement that donald
trump
uh put out here um through his save
america
whatever okay joe biden kept talking
about how good of a job he's doing on
the distribution of the vaccine
that was developed by operation warp
speed or quite simply the trump
administration
so trump's taking credit for the vaccine
here he's not doing well at all
he's way behind schedule and people are
refusing to take the vaccine because
they don't
trust his administration the bottom of
it's just off screen and i apologize
they don't trust the election results
and they certainly don't trust the fake
news
which is refusing to tell the truth so
there are
a few things here to talk about the
first is just the unconscionable danger
of this
for better or worse this guy has meant
many tens of millions of ardent
supporters
who are still hanging on his every word
they are looking
for any reason not to get vaccinated and
this is a concerted effort
that we're hearing donald trump is
taking pleasure
in joe biden falling short of
the vaccine goal that he had set of 70
first dose by july 4th or whatever the
case may be
now the reason that that's happening is
because trump and people like trump are
encouraging people not to get vaccinated
asked about louisiana's low vaccination
rate senator bill cassidy a republican
blamed the white house and partisan
statements
for the fact that his own constituents
don't trust uh white house officials
when they say hey the vaccine is safe
now trump also says the vaccine is safe
but now trump is saying well you can't
trust the administration listen to this
your stay of louisiana is the
fifth lowest in vaccination rate only 36
of people in your state have been fully
vaccinated you're
a medical doctor your thoughts about
that
about the the resistance to the vaccine
in louisiana and is there anything you
can and plan to do about it
a couple things first people are
surprised when
citizens don't trust government when you
have partisan comments coming out of the
white house regarding next jim crow laws
are people like senator schumer in the
white house not cooperating on a
bipartisan bill
oh here we're going to be partisan but
over here
you better trust us that just doesn't
work right
so consider that when trump says
people don't trust the administration
or the election results so they're not
getting vaccinated
and bill cassidy says it's partisan
statements
from the white house that make people
not get vaccinated
if this is really the trump vaccine
trump says it is
many of his supporters say trump did the
vaccine shouldn't they want to get that
vaccine
why wouldn't you get the vaccine that
donald trump developed for you now
then trump says well people won't get
vaccinated because they don't trust the
biden administration
biden as far as they believe doesn't
have anything to do with the vaccine
if it was trump's it was developed
during trump's presidency
it was approved by donald trump's fda
what is there not to trust
it's the same vaccine joe biden did hire
more vaccinators that's true
but that makes the vaccine untrustworthy
and also what about every other country
that approved the same vaccines
if there's something about joe biden's
administration that you don't trust
as silly as that would be when it comes
to this issue
why wouldn't you just say well hold on
look at all these health agencies
from other countries that also said it's
safe but it's all a ruse
trump doesn't believe any of this stuff
trump got the vaccine
and he knows it's safe trump wants to
hurt joe biden
and trump is realizing if fewer people
get vaccinated even if they die
even if their own they're his own
supporters it looks bad for joe biden
thanks to trump it's not going well and
now he's using that against biden that's
the full story
it's a former president weaponizing
his own unvaccinated followers to try to
hurt joe biden even if they die
asha rangapa former fbi agent and
current law professor
and cnn contributor tweeted about this
and she said in response to my tweet
about this
it's a loyalty test if they support him
and believe he won
they should be willing to die for him
now the side effect
is that some of his followers will die
simply for choosing not to get
vaccinated and here is trump
bragging that his own anti-vaccine
campaign and that being carried out by
other fellow republicans is working
the effect is people will die i don't
know that it's really going to hurt joe
biden joe biden as we talked about
earlier
his approval rating on covid is really
high
but it's going to kill off some trump
supporters and would be trump supporters
now seriously
what would your average trump supporter
say
when told you know trump was vaccinated
in january
and he did it in secret he didn't even
admit that he was vaccinated until march
but publicly even though he got the
vaccine he's trying to discourage his
followers from getting vaccinated if you
what do you think
a trump supporter would say if you went
to them and said that my thought is many
will react by saying
trump didn't really get vaccinated when
he said it
he was lying well but then why would he
lie about that
two months later it's all part of some
plan he was either forced to deep state
this who knows
they will have some explanation for it
but it is the weaponization
of lack of vaccine against joe biden
but the after effect is he's going to
kill off a bunch of his own supporters
fox news reporter peter ducey is back in
the white house press briefing room
and is simply determined to end up
humiliating himself at absolutely every
opportunity now i want to be really
clear here because
every time we talk about stuff like this
i get emails david how are you now
just accepting everything that the white
house press secretary no no no no
every white house press secretary
distorts answers selectively
flame frames everything that an
administration does in the best possible
light this is their job
that being said there is a real
difference when gensake
replaced kaylee mcinanni when joe biden
became president and donald trump left
there was a significant change which was
that at least in principle the briefings
became about
substance and most reporters were able
to start asking
mostly substantive questions you still
get
pr answers that's the role of a press
secretary i'm not denying that
fox news's peter ducey is a notable
exception to most
reporters are trying to ask substantive
questions he's been focused
from day one on asking bizarre leading
loaded
inaccurate and even childless questions
constantly trying to trap
gensake and even joe biden sometimes in
gotcha type situations and peter ducey
did the exact same thing on friday
that's the most recent press briefing
uh as as of right now i think there is
one scheduled for a little bit later
today
and jen saki was having absolutely none
of it
peter ducey here is trying to jump all
over a report
that the u.s surgeon general's office
put out which is that
there is a small number of primary
disseminators of covid and vaccine
disinformation
on social media 12 people in fact we've
known for some time that a huge portion
of the anti-vax disinformation
originates from a small number of
accounts
they've been tracking vaccine
disinformation at the surgeon general's
level
and peter ducey frames it as a personal
targeted spying campaign
and uh here is how that exchange went
take a listen to this right
okay so these 12 people who you have on
a list
12 individuals do they even this idea of
a list as nefarious how else do you
categorize things
instead of a list you have a what by
definition if you if you're aware of 12
people it's colloquially a list but he's
even trying to weaponize
list so then later right-wingers can say
this is a mccarthyite list of some kind
okay
did somebody at the surgeon general's
office is going through their
profile i'm happy to get you the
citation of where that comes from
there's no secret list
i will tell you that these are people
who are sharing information
on public platforms on facebook
information that is traveling
is inaccurate our biggest concern here
and i frankly think it should be
your biggest concern is the number of
people who are dying around the country
because
that's not his biggest concern john no
that's it's it's just not
getting misinformation that is leading
them to not take a vaccine
young people old people kids children
this is all being a lot of them are
being impacted by misinformation big
concern though
i think for a lot of people on facebook
is that now this is
big brother watching you they're more
concerned about that than people dying
right most people on facebook are saying
why is the anti-vaccine stuff even being
allowed on facebook
true because of a pandemic where
misinformation is traveling on social
media platforms
that feels unlikely to me if you have
the data to back that up i'm happy to
discuss it
so this is quite well handled it's not
just
some gensake victory party gensake is a
mouthpiece for the administration this
is her job it's no special virtue
but she's doing a good job of pointing
out hold on the vaccine disinformation
leads to death
that should be the primary concern 99
plus percent of hospitalizations are
unvaccinated
99.2 percent of the deaths last month
were unvaccinated
and in comes steve do see again and this
is how you craft
narrative to later repeat on fox news
announcement from yesterday for how long
has the administration been spying
on people's profiles looking for vaccine
misinformation well that was quite a
loaded and inaccurate question
um which i would refute well peter first
of all
as you know we're we're in a regular
touch with with a range of media outlets
as as let me finish as we are
as he's just like an insufferable little
kid we are
in regular touch with social media
platforms
this is publicly open information people
sharing information online just as you
are
all reporting information on your news
stations
okay announcement from yesterday so um
uh but by the way just to be thorough
very well sourced this gensake is
communicating about research that found
12 people are behind a huge amount
of the vaccine hoax information
disinformation
on social media okay there's a very good
npr article about it from a couple
months ago
it's been continued to to be looked at
researchers found 12 people are
responsible for the bulk
of the misleading claims and outright
lies about covet vaccines that
proliferate on facebook
instagram and twitter the disinformation
dozen produced 65
of the shares of anti-vaccine
misinformation on social media platforms
so
there's no doubt about the data but
the concern with imaginary spying when
what we're talking about
is the enforcement of terms of service
and a study of where this stuff is
coming from
the priorities are completely backwards
and steve
steve peter ducey steve ducey's son
continuing to just make a fool out of
himself
but the problem is a lot of the trump
supporters don't see it this way
you might say a normal person would see
this and they would say hold on a second
99 of the hospitalized are unvaccinated
99 of the deaths are unvaccinated now
if you perpetuate anti-vax
disinformation which prevents people
from getting vaccinated
you're essentially leading to people's
deaths that's
incredibly serious and absolutely
immoral the focus should be on stopping
that
but no it's about the surgeon general's
office quote spying
and unfortunately it works it works on
the fox news audience it works on
the legacy rush limbaugh audience that
is now kind of fragmented and listening
to different shows
uh so completely missing the plot and
peter ducey continuing to make a fool
out of himself on a regular basis
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
okay so i'm going to be really honest
and transparent with you i don't know if
caitlyn jenner's candidacy for the
california gubernatorial recall election
is a serious campaign or a publicity
stunt i actually can't tell i'm having
trouble determining it for myself
and part of the reason i can't tell is
that every interview that she does
is so bizarre and so disconnected from
reality and it admit transmits
not only no actual understanding of the
political issues but not even an
interest in appearing to understand the
political issues that
part of me sort of hopes it's merely a
publicity campaign
because as a political campaign it's
completely pathetic
it's in theory a pretty interesting
candidacy a republican trans woman
running
supporter of trump despite endless
hostility uh
from trump to the trans community very
much hostility from trumpists
to the trans community and in fact the
last time i covered
caitlyn jenner interview many of you
were super interested in it the last
clip about one of her interviews got
over a million views on youtube that
wasn't even that long ago
so jenner is interviewed again this
weekend now that the recall
is happening in california interviewed
by judge jeanine pirro on fox news
and i have to tell you i am again
questioning caitlyn's connection to
reality she seems not even connected to
the most fundamental and basic facts on
the ground
in this first clip somehow i mean again
the enemy is george soros how can it be
that it's it's
always george soros let's start with the
first clip
filling him in on how george soros has
been funding all these
all these lawyers and low ends very
liberal lawyers
yes and you know this field very well um
and he keeps running then to getting him
giving
as much money as they want because he
figures he's got to change this country
from the bottom up yeah he wants to
destroy this country
so there it is uh it there is no
campaign
at which a republican can't interject
the idea
that george soros's evil intentions
are being uh promulgated and perpetuated
at every level with his money and
lawyers and of course of
of course we can get into is this just
more thinly veiled anti-semitism i don't
even think we need to
because we have so many other things to
talk about you might have also noticed
that at the bottom of the screen
there was a quote of caitlyn jenner
saying we have to get tough on crime
whenever i hear tough on crime i always
ask which
specific crimes are we not tough enough
on
and also when get when you say get tough
what do you mean
is it we're not prosecuting enough is it
that the punishments
aren't strict enough do we need more
jail time you really have to make them
tell us
tell us tough on crime is meaningless in
the abstract
which crimes and what aspect do we need
to be tougher on like if people came to
me
and then say they say david sir what
crimes are we not tough enough on i
would say
there's not enough effort being put into
even
policing and prosecuting white-collar
crime and then the sentences are also
not nearly harsh enough we are too
focused on street crime
including drug related stuff and not
focused enough on white collar crime
most fraud and embezzlement isn't dealt
with harshly enough okay so
let's put them in the position of having
to tell us exactly which crimes they're
talking about
next clip here jenner is asked by janine
pirro
whether she'd support trump in 2024 and
whether donald trump should run
should donald trump run in 2024. that's
his
decision would you support him if he did
if i was governor of the state of
california i i
would uh obviously i would support him
what now
what do you mean as governor what just
would you support him is just the
question
what if you weren't governor there you
go would you still support him
um yes i i still would support him i i
do
not like what's happening in this
country right now so then what's the
point of mentioning
if i were governor like it's all just
kind of confused and very bizarre
and then let's look at one longer
section about i don't even know what but
it gets into woke and other you know
buzzwords all right now you're
considered to be one of our nation's
greatest
athletes and heroes in the moment now is
that even true
yeah i don't even know that that's true
is caitlyn jenner one of the greatest
athletes in american history that
it sounds strange to me it sounds like
maybe fox news is saying that
because caitlyn jenner is a republican
but i don't even know i mean i'm not
taking anything away
from jenner's achievements but
that strikes me as is not really even
accurate but that's not the point today
okay
across the finish line in 1976
for that decathlon some fan ran across
the finish
line on the track uh and gave you a flag
and you waved that flag proudly and that
became a very iconic
moment not just then but throughout
history in terms of of the olympics
right
how do you compare today to them
boy has it changed remember that was
1976 our country's bicentennial year we
were just
three weeks earlier the biggest fourth
of july celebration the country's ever
had celebrating 200 years
right um i've seen through
the years the deterioration of our flag
of the flag has deteriorated now i'm
guessing caitlyn means
a deterioration of respect for the flag
that that's what i assume
caitlyn means which i disagree with but
it's all
just mumble jump mumbo jumbo confusion
love of country
i still love our country oh okay okay we
certainly have issues
but i'm a patriot right my father my
grandfather
fought in world war one you know my dad
stormed the beaches of normandy
first boats on 364 guys in his division
60 came back alive you know to fight for
our freedoms
and i've always had that in my heart
patriotism
i love this country i was very proud to
put that flag up
um but i've seen it go down to where now
we just saw this when the hammer thrower
uh disrespect our flag
uh and then that bothers me let's talk
about gwen berry
you know she came in third place and
she thought it was all about her she
said they played the national anthem
when they knew that she didn't like it
um she did she
understands she didn't like okay
all right all right but the united
states was her ticket
to those olympics they were the trials
should she be allowed to go forward when
she's indicated that she now this is
like a hyper nationalist perspective
you are you're there because the u.s
has sports and you were able to train in
your sport and so
therefore no action even a
constitutionally protected
action uh is allowed
because it's inherently disrespectful to
the fact that you should be
only grateful to the united it's a hyper
nationalist idea which
is accepted without question on places
like fox news pretty much rejects the
flag rejects the national anthem
you know what that's a tough question
why because i don't i like
individual freedoms number one i think
now this is actually the right instinct
by caitlyn jenner
it's the right instinct protect
individual freedoms right
i think people like that who are going
to disrespect our flag
um to make a political statement and
maybe get more hits
you know on social media um
technically have a right to do that
technically look at janine's face
caitlyn jenner has the right instinct
here which is it's
i wouldn't even say technically they
have a right to do that
displaying 10 flags if that's what you
want to do
is a constitutionally protected free
speech statement
and turning away from the flag is as
well and they're equal
under the law but they we also have the
right they have the right to
deserve this the consequences that will
come out of their actions
that's right and what i wish is that
caitlyn jenner applied this same
analysis to social media
and the idea that their free speech
doesn't mean freedom from consequences
of speech and as long as it's not a
government sanction
the olympics say you these are the rules
about how you have to address the flag
they would be
they would be able to do that and then
people could react to that by saying
well
i don't like that i'll boycott the
olympics or whatever but caitlyn
jenner's instinct is actually it's a
moment of clarity
and janine doesn't like it are there
enough consequences to someone like
that's
very excellent question in so many cases
no sometimes you become big stars for
that like getting commercials for nike
and things like that uh that bothers me
tremendously
this woke that world that we're living
in right now
is i don't know honestly i don't know
how we move forward
we have to move forward and be strong we
have to move forward with love of
country
so there is the conflict where caitlyn
actually has the right instinct about
individual freedom
but still has to sort of kowtow to woke
is bad and how do we even deal with woke
so
a confused interview an interesting
moment of clarity
it's the moment where janine pirro
pushed back the most but big picture
continued confusion sort of coming out
of the pseudo candidacy of caitlyn
jenner
let me know what you think we're
continuing to learn more and more about
um
the uh proximity the the proximity to a
coup that took place with donald trump
uh in those late days of his
administration i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this but indeed we are we
are learning that that coup was much
closer than we thought
much of this relates to statements by
general mark milley that we now
know about because of the book from
carol lennon and philip rucker
report from cnn the top u.s military
officer
chairman of the joint chiefs general
mark milley was so shaken that then
president donald trump and his allies
might attempt to coup or take other
dangerous or illegal measures after the
november election
that millie and other top officials
informally planned
for different ways to stop trump
according to excerpts of an upcoming
book
obtained by cnn they were so worried
they actually got together and said
how do we stop a trump coup if he
attempts it um
it was a kind of saturday night massacre
in reverse lennog and rucker wright
the book describes how millie and other
joint chiefs discussed
a plan to resign one by one rather than
carry out orders from trump
that they consider to be illegal
dangerous or ill-advised
this is absolutely incredible the book
recounts
the book recounts how for the first time
in modern us history
the nation's top military officer whose
role is to advise the president
was preparing for a showdown with the
commander-in-chief because he feared a
coup attempt after trump lost the
november election
the author explained the authors
explained milly's growing concerns that
personnel moves that put trump acolytes
in positions of power at the pentagon
after the election including the firing
of defense secretary mark esper
and the resignation of attorney general
william barr were the sign of something
sinister to come
milly spoke to friends lawmakers and
colleagues about the threat of a coup
and the joint chief's chairman felt he
had to be on guard for what might come
quote they may try but they're not going
to effing succeed
milly told his deputies you can't do
this without the military
you can't do this without the cia and
the fbi we are the guys with the guns
this is how much those
at the centers of power feared that this
was what donald trump was going to
attempt to do
now donald trump reacted to this report
and put out a statement
saying despite massive voter fraud and
irregularities during the 2020
presidential election scam that we are
now
seeing play out in very big and
important states i never threatened or
spoke about to anyone a coup of our
government
so ridiculous sorry to inform you but an
election is my form of coup
and if i was going to do a coup one of
the last people i would want to do it
with is general mark milley
he got his job only because the world's
most overrated general james mattis
could not stand him
had no respect for him and would not
recommend him to me the fact that mattis
didn't like him just like obama didn't
like him and actually fired millie was a
good thing
not a bad thing trump going on to say in
any event i lost respect for millie
when we walked together to st john's
church which was still
smoldering from a radical liberal
radical left fire set the day before
side by side and the following day
millie choked like a dog
in front of the fake news when they told
him they thought he should not have been
walking with the president which turned
out to be incorrect
he apologized profusely on and on
certainly not the type of person i would
be talking coo
with i'm not into coups so what's
fascinating about this
is that trump did seem to want a coup
it just seems maybe he wasn't planning
to use the military but millie's larger
point was correct which was trump and
the movement
tried to subvert the election through
potentially illegal and violent means
it's horrifying
it's absolutely dystopian and uh
the the the real coup attempt was saying
you won an election you lost
and sending lawyers around even
incompetent ones like rudy giuliani
and sydney powell and jenna ellis to try
to steal it back
that's the horrifying reality he tried
it he would try it again
and the fact that he lost or wasn't able
to do it is why he's now using this
language but absolutely crazy stuff
i actually do plan to read this book i
alone can fix it i
i never read these types of books i
didn't read the woodward ones i didn't
read the michael wolfe ones i just have
so much other stuff history sociology
philosophy
on my my stack of books to read but the
lenig
rucker book seems very much worth
reading and they're typically quick read
so i do plan to check it out
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
last week i said i don't gloat when an
anti-vaxxed person dies of covet i don't
we got a really strong voicemail from
the eggman who we haven't heard from for
a little while
he has a different perspective on this
take a listen hi dave
you and pat keep talking about the
anti-vaxxers and like ashley babbitt and
all these people are our victims and you
feel that you have empathy you feel bad
for them
um i have empathy i'm sorry eggman
you call them victims they're victims of
misinformation
dave i'm gloating in their death just
like they gloated in rbg's
death okay here's the deal right you
have to be
proposed for some reason in some way to
fall for that
um those those fake i think eggman means
predisposed
facts okay they're victims they're
victims of their own hatred and racist
uh feelings they're not innocent in this
you tell two people that the the
the vaccine doesn't work one believes it
one doesn't
one that doesn't believe it doesn't
believe it for reasons they already
have predetermined in their own mind
racist
[ __ ] up hateful reasons so they're not
innocent
you feel so bad but aren't they victims
because they were indoctrinated into
that is my point
for ashley babbitt she's a horrible
freaking person
i say dave i'm just saying we need to
have less empathy for them because they
have no empathy for
us wow so basically it's like an eye for
an eye from the egg man
the liberals will never win if we feel
bad for them and think of them as
victims
they think of themselves as victims and
you're feeding that
the ideology has to be rooted out i
don't
suggest we do anything short of a
hundred and ten percent rooting out the
ideology
but gloating about the death seems like
it's over the line for me
and i think most people in the audience
agree we've got a great bonus show
planned for you today
texas texas state senate has passed a
bill
to remove required lessons about civil
rights movements from the curricula
of public schools horrifying a utah
pharmacist
gave a bunch of people cards saying they
had been vaccinated
when they had not been vaccinated and
lastly we are about to see the first
trump rioter
sentenced what are we expecting what are
the charges
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at join joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman